Now as you'll remember from the last unit, just having a huge number of potential solutions
of course does not show that your problem is NP complete.
But it can be an indicator if you cannot come up with any substantially better algorithm.
Dave currently cannot come up with a substantially better algorithm,
so he wonders could his problem of shortest tour also be NP-complete?
That's why, together with Dave, we will now try to show that indeed
shortest tour is NP-complete.
To do that we will go through these 2 standard steps here.
First of all, we have to show that the problem of shortest tour is in NP.
To do that, as you'll remember from the last time, we actually have to state this problem
as a decision problem. So here's our next quiz for you.
How can Dave state his problem of shortest tour as a decision problem?
Given a graph with distances, what is the shortest tour?
That visits all vertices of course.
The second option would be, given a graph with distances and a number d,
is there a tour of length at most d?
Given the graph with distances, how long is the shortest tour?
Please check the problem statement that states shortest tour as a decision problem.